on
peut faire des choses avec sa tête et
avec son ventre avec la tête on peut
faire des maths ou avoir des discussions
compliquées avec ses parents
nous allons prendre un nouveau départ
alors
est ce que vous en dites aimer
ce lait bien arrangé non
[Musique]
tu viens d'où j'ai demandé quelque chose
reste à montady l'athlé ce que tu
faillite arrête tout de suite tu
t'excuses joy le deal
[Musique]
est ce que tu veux battre nous avons le
coup non je trappe et je veux me
défouler
je m'entraîne je veux devenir kickboxer
c'est tout ce que tu as tient enfin ses
salles kick boxer ça allait revient aux
anges
il se passe beaucoup de choses dans ta
tête t'es pas tout seul tu sais on a
tous nos soucis
là je ne vois pas un tigre joue un
chèque chiale pas je peux pas supporter
[Musique]
secte à me ressaisir et que je dois
réussir
je le sais j'en ai conscience
c'est pour ça que je viens ici
[Musique]
ça doit sortir du ventre
ma mère fait comme si tout allait bien
mon père pense qu'à une seule chose
c'est lui
m
[Musique]